support for me marriage is not
that important anymore i want to have a
partner and i want to be with somebody i
i would like to get married and get
engaged and you know build this
life with someone okay but that's not
something that
that's my like sole purpose in life so
if you were 40 yeah they never got
married
no kids i'm just hypothetical no kids
but you had a good career i would like
would that be enough to satisfy you i
would i always wanted to be a mother so
i i want to be a mom before i'm 40.
yeah because of like all the of course
no that's why i post it that way so i
would definitely want to be a mother and
i would be disappointed if i'm not a
mother okay how about you ally if you
never got married and you're still
working on your career let's say you're
an influencer but you're still single
would that be a disappointment there
would absolutely be a disappointment
that's not how i want my life going down
at all and you know there's something to
be said about if you don't have babies
your dna doesn't go on and you're really
just kind of like well you know life is
pointless i think kids give women
purpose and i think that we lie to women
when we tell them that that's not true
that your job is going to fulfill you
it's not the same thing as watching a
tiny human grow look and look up at you
and learn but you know um i've noticed
sometimes that women will say
that they want kids but they won't say
that they want a specific man's kids and
i think that's an important distinction
how do you mean what's the distinction
there so okay um for people that follow
my content they're pretty familiar that
i had a miscarriage earlier this year i
ended up going to facebook support
groups because i don't know who else to
talk to about that stuff i ended up
going there and i found two very
different schools of thought there are
women that were married and in
relationships where they wanted to have
children but it didn't work out but then
there were other women that were
grieving but they're just looking for a
guy to get the job done like they're
literally hunting for men to impregnate
them they haven't given a thought well i
mean what's the cost going to be to the
child so i think like if we're going to
talk about women wanting to have
children and that's like in the plans
then like you know uh i know sperm is
cheap but we still need it we still need
it so you know what what's up with the
guy where he's where's he at how are we
gonna get him
okay and then pearl if you're 40
youtube blown up million subscribers you
killed it but no husband no kids would
that be satisfying none of it would
matter
like like to me if you have nothing to
pass on and like you
who cares if you're rich if you're alone
you can have all the money in the world
but if you don't have like a family to
go home to that's sad i i um i did this
thing where i interviewed um executives
like top executives in milwaukee and
there was a couple that i interviewed
that like had no family no kids and you
could just see how sad they were
and
like who cares if you have all the
success if you have no one to share it
with yeah that makes me think i have a
couple friends down here in south
florida they're both
i would say very successful estate
planners right so high profile lawyers
estate
planners and they were both you're
familiar with the concept of dinks
dual income no kids oh yes stinks
and they're both you know crushing six
figures easily
um and they were not going to have kids
and then
lo and behold i think after like 10
years of marriage they decided to have
kids now they're on their second kid
because they realized holy [ __ ] i don't
know what i was thinking here okay by
the way is this something this
discussion that we're having right now
is this something that women sit around
and discuss no this is not
just that just uh okay why is this not
uh like guys we will should yo what up
bro you thought girl yeah here's what
i'm thinking yeah like why don't women
have these types of discussion
why does it take saskatchewan
valuetainment subscribe right now to
bring this type of conversation to the
forefront why don't ladies have this
discussion do you want to weigh in
ladies don't have coverage this
discussion right here they both nodded
their head and said no they don't talk
about this do you talk about this kind
of stuff with your friends stuff like
wanting to career woman getting married
yeah being of course being a housewife
rather than an independent woman so
you're saying you do have these
conversations we don't really talk about
all them i try to surround myself with
people who are very ambitious and career
driven so i can learn from them and like
we can all build each other up
so but we never talk about like oh if i
don't get married if i don't do this
like we're all talking about just like
so building a career one of the are you
ready to take some calls in a second to
tell you um one sec but one of the terms
that i constantly hear because i'm
asking
all sorts of people um
what specifically women
on
traits or qualities they find attractive
in a man
and
a term that constantly gets put out
there is ambition
he's ambitious oh my god he hasn't made
it yet but he's ambitious he's got some
drive he's got ambition that's
attractive it's attractive quality
i don't know if men are like oh that
girl right there she's ambitious i love
how ambitious she is they're not okay so
guys i don't care about that your
boyfriend he loves the fact that you're
ambitious yeah but you said boyfriend is
it oh meaning that's not her husband how
do you mean i would be curious right so
if coco and this guy right they end up
working on the long term
if he's a masculine man i'd be i would
wonder if you'd be in the kitchen making
some breakfast we both make breakfast i
made it today he made it yesterday okay
i mean i thought for you guys no i don't
i don't need photo proof i'm just saying
i would be curious to see if that
femininity switch would flip for you
so is there a switch that women have to
basically tap into is that what you're
saying well i think women should
consider femininity from the beginning
but the west is just really awful at it
i think eastern culture has femininity
figured out way more but i think some
women they're ambitious boss babe that's
all i care about but then they meet a
strong masculine man they're like okay
you know what like maybe i'll work
part-time you know how okay how do you
want your steak medium rare what kind of
side do you want i've seen it happen in
real time women are like i would never
serve a man and then they have the hot
plate in their hands i cook for my man
yeah i have no shame in admitting that i
mean in europe we learn how to cook like
every woman pretty much knows how to
cook but that's not something that like
i'm not gonna not work because like i
need to make a meal like making a meal
is
something very normal in my life
there's a difference between making a
meal and making a home
yeah explain that please
well i mean there's
a maid can like clean for you a cook can
cook for you but only a wife can make a
home
so that's like family traditions culture
and like what are you passing on to your
children
gotcha so that's again your dream life
is to be
you know happy wife happy life but your
dream like forget about a million
subscribers you want to make a house a
home
yeah i just want a lot of kids like i
think i'm pretty cool so i feel like if
there's like five of me running around
it'd be even cooler you're ready for
what kind of stuff by the way guys in
the super chat we're gonna be answering
your questions today uh we're
these women as as
i just want to thank you guys for being
here and everyone has a different uh
opinion respect everyone's getting along
great but i do want to answer some of
the questions from
um valuetainers out there in the
audience natalia you got something that
you want to ask um so there's one
question from nate uh throughman he said
why would a man that values marriage
want to marry you
that's a question me just in general
why okay
so i'm like yeah so why would a man
who values marriage want to marry you
okay go down the line here coco you go
first why would a man who values
marriage would want to marry me yes
i'm not really sure if i understand that
question
so a guy who wants to get married yeah
why would he want to marry you oh so
basically you're asking me what it
brings to the table or what is that yeah
is that what it is sure and we'll go
down the line this you're not being
singled out okay no no no
um
well
it's a very strange question honestly
for me but i would want to marry
somebody that i see building i if i'm
with my boyfriend now and i see
marrying him one day if we get to that
point because he is a good partner he
helps me do certain things and i help
him and i
i would it's easier to live life with
somebody